I don't know if you've noticed how much
cocaine is around a lot I was at a party
where a bunch of girls gave they were
they all did pills and I went what are
you guys doing and they go to adderall
but I I'm high I'm on cocaine
somebody said here's naturalist good for
ADHD and I wanted to write I was like
should I take it and I took it I took
half an adderall hey guys
for me that's cocaine I was like that
this isn't helping me it makes me feel
good and I feel like I have a lot of
energy when I was like I don't know III
I'm not doing it again cuz I like it
they took you take a lot of adderall
you're gonna feel [ __ ] amazing really
oh dude you stay away from it look at me
right now look at me right now stay away
from it oh I've done cocaine alright
stay away from that - it's like that
that the first high you get from coffee
quadruple I'm always chasing that we all
are we all are I drink coffee I'll admit
it because I've been chasing that
[ __ ] feeling from day one look of
Atlantic never I'll get a little whoa
wow like it was great it was [ __ ]
great but don't ever try cocaine though
I would say that for a fact if you like
kratom oh I know a guy have you ever
that Vinick yeah take the best coffee
how you've ever had in quadruple it I
can get some I'll tell you what man it's
you feel fantastic what do you take this
is stimulant I'm not recommending why
I'm not recommending it I see this press
opines chocolate-covered espresso beans
[ __ ] I'd wonder where I was shaking
hey I need to be dead honest with me
right now
yeah are you addicted to Adderall look
dude have I been thinking about it up
the way you were hyping it up for me
adderall is better here you'll promote
me at all you're not promoting it and
there's a job done no don't use I'm
saying at all should be treated like
cocaine good drug addict Alan Monday
yeah this adderall Monday that on Monday
it's half an adderall is okay sometimes
it on Monday no it's not stay away from
it too late dude
don't touch my rugs certain molecules
can send you into a tailspin [ __ ] these
drugs